and we gotta ask you - what did you know
obviously you're sick and tired type of
Kevin Spacey but well the hell was it
worried because he's such a great actor
cloud-like a great show like we should
we could just talk about house of cards
being awesome yeah now that has to be it
because obviously it's a great project
to be involved with as an artist and
creatively and whether it's when things
kind of broke were you shot were you
shocked or were you like yeah I kind of
suspected I wasn't shocked
you weren't no but I mean like I had a
great work working relationship with him
you know he was very friendly to me I
don't say he goes but I'll be honest I
looked at you and I'm like I get it let
me ask you in general when someone is
happy that you're there let's just say
when somebody who's maybe into you and
you're not into that person in general
how do you allow them to know I'm glad
you're happy I'm here but when people
how do you allow them to know that I
mean I think it's to me it's pretty
simple you know what's he what's he
gonna do you know he can't I mean I'm
just I'm just being you know I'm talking
to him and I'm being polite and I'm
laughing you know it we're if we're for
having fun but um you know this just did
he try to get touchy a handsy feeling no
well one time when here
he was like Joe we were doing this big
scene and it was a lot of a lot of
extras around I was like this big
ballroom and I walked in it was like my
first scene in the day and he'd already
been shooting and he was in the middle
of changing his shirt and and then I
walked in and he was like Joe he was
like very happy to see me
and then while I walked up he was like
tucking in his shirt and then but his
you know the pants was button but the
fly was open so while he was like
tucking in he like ran his hands through
the flyer and wanted to shake my hand
so I was like I give you a fist bump
like that was turned around when you say
that you weren't shocked is it because
you would hurt things or just because
you're like anybody that tries to shake
your hand through their fly is probably
got something going on no but I mean I
think you know with Kevin it was sort of
I mean I don't want to like get into it
too much but it's like he you'd heard
stories you know but it's all rumors
yeah yeah yeah who do we have that said
Jon Bernthal came on and yes talking
about and he said that he was abusive to
people unsaid I was surprised that John
said that but he goes did you notice
that was he was he he was nice to you on
baby dry yeah yeah but did you see we
were yelling at people or no no no I
mean it was perfectly professional okay
so you saw the power side